i love leon
and i want to marry him someday let's go
[Laughter]
what is resident evil 4 that is a loaded
question resident evil 4 is the fourth
installment in a long ongoing
horror survival franchise from capcom
resident evil
probably
the turning point of the series love it
or hate it it revolutionized what we
knew of survival horror at the time by
completely redoing
the controls the mechanics and the feel
of survival horror games it's the goat
it's as close as you can get to a
perfect video game and it means so
much to so many people there's a reason
why they keep releasing it over and over
and over and over again anyway you know
what this is all about i can remember
exactly what my uh first memory of
resident evil 4 was um because it was
the trailer which featured leon on an
airship and in a haunted house and being
pursued by the
ghost hook man it was
a completely different game it was
actually a horror game
it had supernatural elements there were
fixed camera angles but there was also
something very peculiar in the gameplay
and that was the over-the-shoulder
camera
i remember seeing how the camera
was behind leon kennedy like over his
shoulder and this like very cinematic
16x9
bars on top
look that just i remember being so blown
away this looks so cool i remember like
touching it being like how do i get this
i just remembered something i bought a
gamecube for resident evil 4. i
essentially
uh how do i phrase this i didn't go to
school that day
i ran away
i essentially
went to gamestop
got the game called my homies we all
caught school together we told our
friends we were sick went to my friend
dan's house and we said
no one can know what's going on here
this is our domain and we played the
game for three days straight i
distinctly remember going to gamestop
to buy it with my brother who's older
than me who didn't know i was working
under the table as the last boy
and bought this game in full with cash
and him being like
where did you get that money
and feeling extremely uncomfortable
about explaining to him for some reason
that i like
had a side gig
as a 14 year old kid but that is what
paid for a game
that essentially kind of
changed my perception of games
resident evil
4
i think my first memory of resident evil
4
was going through the village and you do
enter a shack and if you quickly turn to
the left you see
one of the villagers a lady that is uh
pinned up to the wall by a pitchfork and
i just remember
seeing that and being like wow that is
that's resident evil the fact that the
ai is shielding their eyes from your
laser pointer so you're pointing in
their face and they're like stop
get out of here i don't want this
they're more intelligent they're more
aggressive they're more coherent of
what's going on i think that's what
makes them a terrifying enemy the
villagers can do so many more things
than zombies can do like there's they're
throwing things at you they're grabbing
you
like enemies will hit you while you're
being grabbed by another guy oh this is
not your mama's resident evil but it was
when like their head burst and all of a
sudden
there's this like
weird alien like parasite thing coming
out of their head
that you could shoot and it wouldn't go
down the enemies were absolutely
terrifying both visually but then from
like a gameplay perspective because it's
like i don't know what to do anymore
like my normal video game tactics
of like shooting a guy in the head do
not work anymore when people used to
call a zombie game they actually uh
they're not zombies they're uh they're
like parasite infected things with mind
control they're not zombies los plagueis
i have to say that las pagas not zombies
if you remember right before that
there's like a cut scene where leon is
kind of having like this like
hallucinogenic like
oh i'm mutating like kind of thing and
then you see that right afterwards
it was like the stakes have gone from
like maybe 50 to 150. that can happen to
leon i have to protect him with my life
with my gamer skills
this game not only did it kind of
reinvent the survival horror genre for
resident evil but it pushed resident
evil in the direction of action horror
at that time it was kind of like we were
getting a lot of fixed camera angle
games even code veronica which was the
first fully 3d resident evil game as far
as the classics go was still slow and
then resident evil 4 comes along and it
is just non-stop action but it wasn't in
a way where it ruined
what we knew from the resident evil
franchise it's that it made you feel
like you were more intimately a part of
it you shoot the guy and he staggers and
then you roundhouse kick him and then he
like flies into all of his friends that
creates your opening now you know
instead of it just being like oh my
opening is like awkwardly like
moving backwards and then like turning
left and then running past like a group
of enemies it was a breath of fresh air
but it was also so jarring to the
resident evil fandom some people loved
it and some people did not i wasn't a
big fan at first when i first played it
this has kind of gone too far away from
what i enjoyed the first time i actually
got hands-on with resident evil 4 and
like sought
as something that was totally different
from what the previous resident evils
had been i was
honestly blown away it wasn't one of
those things like they changed it it was
just i was so enthralled with that i had
never played a game that had done it
even though you felt like you had more
control of your character and that you
could get a head shot on somebody
without
pointing your gun like straight up at
the ceiling for no reason the fact that
they managed to still keep a lot of
tension and horror was pretty remarkable
it made you feel like you were
seeing from the perspective of the
character
in real time about three years ago i
thought i would give it another try
everybody loves the game so i wanted to
try it again with an open mind and i
absolutely fell in love with it oh i
could just vibe out with this game you
know just like turn it on
blast some guys stylishly and like you
know just do really cool stuff you're a
dude with sweet hair a sweet jacket and
you have to go get the president's
daughter period yeah i am gonna fight
everything yeah i'm not gonna run away
i'm tired of running i've been running
for for four or five games i'm standing
my ground i'm gonna take out the las
vlagas i'm gonna stop lord sadler it's
gonna be a great time
the first thing i think of when i think
of resident evil 4 is probably the thing
that everyone thinks of which is the
village at first i was like oh kind of
excited like let me explore village
and then everyone starts swarming at you
and i
panicked you don't know where to go and
they're coming from every angle you
don't feel safe i remember
panicking and i remember going into the
first house i saw and then the ability
like oh my god i can push furniture to
stop them from coming in
and just sweating bullets being like oh
my god oh my god oh my god talk about
sweaty palms i i literally remember
my controller i'd have to like wipe my
hands on my pants and i'm like
like just like freaking out because
you're literally running for your life
you're just so underprepared and so not
ready for anything that's happening
every building you go into there's three
windows that they can climb in or doors
that they can get through i'm terrified
but there's a smile on my face oh no
they're coming after us what do we do i
don't know kill them all i guess defend
yourself and it was always this yeah
this is so awesome we're gonna probably
die kind of vibe and i always love that
and that's when the chainsaw thing revs
up
from chainsaw
it's like that's illegal you can't do
that you can't just throw a chainsaw guy
at me within the first 10 minutes and i
remember being in the room with somebody
else and them all being like oh
[ __ ]
it's just bat it's totally nut case also
in the window would smash and do with
the chainsaw and the the potato sack
would just come in and cut your head off
as i saw his head just fall off the
screen i sat there
and i was just like horrified that that
actually just happened i turned off the
console and like left and did other
things with my life because i was a
little bit younger obviously but that
was just so
overwhelming that was a one-hit kill
that
i never wanted to experience it was too
scary for me it's too scary it's messed
up everything that makes re4 great is
condensed into the very beginning it
throws everything at you it's not for no
reason that that's the thing that
everyone thinks of when they think of
the game it's a
genre-defying moment but it works so
incredibly well because it also it like
it runs on
a timer and you don't know that so
you're just
scrambling you're just waiting for that
bell to ring and then it's like oh that
was intense
[Music]
then when it's all over you get the
classic where's everybody going bingo
okay the first thing i think of when i
think of resident evil 4 for whatever
reason when this question was just
asking me just now the thing that popped
into my head was leon kennedy saying
where's everyone going
bingo do you think it would be
uh the combat and the over-the-shoulder
because that was so
incredibly mind-blowing when it came out
but
i guess it's bingo knight
it's how they uh they introduced the
title i mean as soon as he says that the
camera pans out and you get resident
evil 4. i think that's why it's so
memorable the dialogue is fantastic no
thanks bro no thanks bro they just keep
like rattling off like you like you
think like the one liner that you're at
is the best and then you progress
further into the game and then it's like
through the roof again i've sent my
right hand to dispose of you your right
hand comes off my favorite one always
and i feel like i'm the only one that
says this
uh and i say to this day in my own in my
own life whenever i see a dog is
hey it's that dog and it just sounds so
unnatural it's just like it's that dog
it's a dog it's like so
weird
but i always say it i don't know why i'm
a weird person pretty much everything
leon says it's just like
incredible
it keeps the camp switch down the whole
way through leona's kennedy is like an
80s
he's like an 80s action star jock [ __ ]
leon specifically is like to me he is
resident evil 4. that's definitely
the only thing i think of when resident
evil 4
enters my brain it's like god leon's so
cool what the hell
the dialogue was
basically aimed directly at me um as a
14 year old boy
so i loved it i absolutely loved it it's
basically just quite embarrassing i did
some research on this actually and the
japanese game doesn't have these cheesy
lines but it's such a defining factor
resident evil 4. it's why i have such a
hard time imagining it being remade
so much of that game's identity
is
it's dialogue it's perfect honestly the
dialogue in resident evil 4 was very
cringe but that was also very fitting
for the series the series has always had
one-liners uh cringy dialogue it's what
it's known for it's part of its charm i
think that's why i can forgive ashley in
the same way that i can forgive every
other cliche and stereotype in that game
because it's very clearly deliberately
trying to do
everything badly
you know i know a lot of people like
give ashley a lot of grief they throw a
lot of shade at her i don't hate ashley
she doesn't really even do that much in
the game for the most part you're just
like she's in a dumpster most of the
time i'm just pretty messed up
basically leave her in a dumpster while
you clear out a room and be like all
right let's go there's another dumpster
getting in a dumpster again and that's
where she belongs if i see a dumpster
she's going in it
what if ashley didn't suck you were just
a bad player that leon help and the
constantly getting captured and the
constantly dying and just the annoyances
that wouldn't happen if you just
protected her and you were better at the
game granted i'm terrible at the game
and i'm constantly hearing leon help
[Music]
leon pervert leon help help me leon leon
that's ashley that's all she says
counter to what leon's goals are it's
almost a relief whenever ashley gets
kidnapped again because you're just like
all right well she's she's she's not my
problem for the immediate future
ashley what's going on
your job is to escort her and it is part
of the game and i honestly don't think i
have as big of an issue with her as most
people do definitely my biggest
unpopular opinion but i actually love
ashley people hate on her she's really
funny i think that's the entire idea she
is very very funny
hey overall i didn't mind her i thought
she was necessarily part of the story i
think without her being an escort lots
of the challenge wouldn't and the stress
probably wouldn't be there as much i
know that she you know gets grabbed and
picked up but the parts where you have
to play is actually just on her own and
she's gotta defend herself i think she
does a pretty good job one of my
favorite moments in re4 is when you
actually do get to play as ashley you're
just so vulnerable during those sections
where
you have to like wander around and it
becomes a survival horror game again
specifically there's the suits of armor
that will like chop down on you but i
think they kind of do some fake outs
where like some of them do it but some
of them don't so i remember the whole
time just being like incredibly on edge
you're just carefully trying to make
your way through this environment and
there's just like it all culminates into
this really annoying but also iconic in
its own right like slide puzzle that
like nobody ever knows how to do you
know it's just like just fiddle with
that for a while there aren't a lot of
moments in horror games that scare me
but in this one i specifically remember
having to actually pause the game and
take a mental break once the
regenerators came out
and then just like the way they move
like how frantic they're like they're
they're twitching and they've got their
teeth and their glowing eyes and the
sounds that they make and you just hear
they're like
i always refer to it as it makes pug
sounds the way it breathes i don't want
to listen to those things i don't want
to hear that thing i don't want to grab
me like shoot with spikes through me i
don't want to [ __ ] deal with it i
think they also do that really cool
thing that games sometimes do where
you're like going through a facility and
you're picking up notes and they're
saying like oh this thing we're working
on it's like really horrible and you go
into the next room it's like the
horrible things escaped oh no and then
you go to the next room and there's like
a dead body and it's like oh the
horrible thing did something really
horrible i can't believe it and then
you're like oh i wonder what's going to
happen in this room and then you think
you killed them because you shot their
leg and they're on the floor
and then suddenly they jump and they
grab leon by the neck it's
terrifying but then you get to guys like
the gyarador who you have to like
essentially sneak around
[Music]
i will never forget the first time
playing that with a friend next to me
and like the feeling we both had of like
like as this thing was like running your
way
if you don't know what you're doing
that's that they are incredibly fast
they they do so much damage that you're
in a tiny room
you need to have good aim you have to
not panic hearing it scream like when
it's like
if he grabs you like that's it like it's
like one of the scariest death scenes
ever like with his claws through your
head and then through your torso
terrifying
when you're surrounded in the cabin look
[Music]
you're still not quite strong enough
there's way more enemies than you're
used to seeing they basically all of
them have the parasite head so they're
like extra strong you escape upstairs
and then they start coming in through
the windows upstairs while they're
coming up the stairs from downstairs
luis is just like there with his gun and
he's like
great job leon
like he shoots like one bullet every
minute and then he's like oh help me
like
help yourself [ __ ] face
there's a lot of moments that really
take you off guard in that game i keep
forgetting how much mad there is in
there and uh nothing is madder than
being chased by the giant like
skyscraper sized doll i can't wait for
the resident evil 4 remake to cover that
section specifically and if they don't
cover it
they've bottled it they've absolutely
bottled it
you three in the cages that might be one
of the scariest boss fights just in
video games this giant nightmare
tongue
axe blade tentacle thing chasing you
through like a series of suspended cages
you just don't want to be there i really
love the um
the del largo boss fight
he's very unpredictable like what he's
gonna do and you're like literally
tethered to this like
building-sized monster so you're you're
just stuck in this situation you don't
have your guns and even if you did they
wouldn't do anything so leon has to like
use his harpoons it's exciting and
thrilling and scary and like it's good
fun one of the biggest jump scares is
right before the boss battle you're
about to get on the boat for the first
time and you shoot the water
the fish monster just comes out and
takes you el gigante of course is just
he's definitely my second favorite and
it's interesting because they literally
happen one after another
you're like dude what am i gonna do and
then suddenly the dog appears and helps
you fight him off and it's
like the coolest thing like i just
remember being like why is the dog oh my
god they're these massive set pieces
almost like shadow of the colossus to a
degree right but obviously not as large
you could jump up on his back like
shadow of the colossus and stab his
parasite there was just something so
enthralling about taking down this huge
ogre looking character and then it's
like aim for the open spot and it's this
gross
tentacle bug thing and you're like oh i
hate this but i also want to kill it i
want to squish it because it's gross and
i want this ogre to stay down i really
remember krauser very fondly it's a well
i remember a lot of it being quick time
event heavy but at the time it was so
cool
i think the fight between you and
krauser is like one of the coolest
things i remember being young oh this is
so cool like two tough guys fighting
with knives and i'm like pressing
buttons to make them like make it look
cool like yeah i'm sweet i'm sweet it's
kind of worth it to see
leon do a backflip that makes it worth
it that's fine but yeah no not a fan but
what you're gonna do honestly i never
really hated them and in resident evil 4
for the most part i thought they were uh
i actually thought they were fine like
running away from the boulder i think is
the first qte moment if i remember
correctly and
uh it was kind of just a surprise like
oh okay i'm in it i'm in it i got it
qtes can very quickly be replaced by
just running away uh from the boulder as
it's coming without taking you out of
the gameplay style and switching the
camera qtes to me it just feels kind of
like a lazy gameplay design and i was
never really a fan of those they're
just silly
fun if it wasn't for the qt's in
resident evil 4 we wouldn't have uh
chris redfield punching a boulder in
resident evil 5 so you know you got make
sacrifices sometimes
before i played resident evil 4 i played
shenmue and shenmue is the game that's
kind of notorious for
defining qt's what we saw though is that
resident evil 4 became so popular that i
think everyone at that point may have
just been okay with qtes as a accepted
form of progression and gameplay loops
and i think that was one of the things
that i would say was kind of a net
negative like we got way too many quick
time events after this game came out but
at the time it was cool it is one of the
most influential games of all time which
is
insane considering resident evil 1 is
also one of the most influential games
of all time it
reshaped
how third-person action games were made
like if you're a third-person action
game you're using the over-the-shoulder
camera and that's that's it all stems
from re4 it became this template that
everyone was using games like dead spice
gears of war the batman arkham series
god of war has an over the shoulder
camera you know last of us is heavily
inspired by it and it was done simply
with a camera placement because it
really brings you into action you see
what made resident evil 4 so great it
translated through five six even seven
and village you see the best of elements
stem at resident evil 4 and even go
backwards to the remakes right i mean
even the resident evil 2 remake followed
it as far as gameplay goes and i think
it's because it really really worked
raising 4 is the game that kind of saved
the genre it brought life to the series
when
so many people were saying that it was
becoming dated even though i love the
original games survival horror as a
whole was kind of being burnt out by
that time
like there wasn't really a lot of life
left in fixed camera angles and 10
controls and all these adventure game
elements that kind of found its way into
it and residing 4 took all that
throughout the window and reinvented not
just the genre but third person action
games without resident evil 4
resident evil as a series would
absolutely i don't think exist or not
exist in in the way it does today it's
probably one of the early
horror games that i really loved
and and also felt like i could play
without getting too scared so um you
know and i love horror media now like
films and
and tv and games and so resident evil 4
probably did have like quite a kind of
considerable effect on me i mean it's
what got me into
uh resident evil as a franchise resident
iv is a game that i've i've played more
times than either of the game i've ever
played period on my counter my original
gamecube file was like 27 times i
probably had played that game through
and that's not including the times i
played it
on the wii
and on my ps4
and on my nintendo switch and now oculus
it taught me a lot as a as a film
student at the time that resident evil 4
came out i was about to graduate from
high school to go into college and to
get a degree in film it taught me a lot
about cinematography what the camera
shows you in action moments but it
doesn't show you in those action moments
there's just so much to learn from
resident evil 4 that i owe it's a game i
probably think about
no at least a couple times a year i had
cut my hair like leon i dyed it blonde i
was wearing like under armour shirts to
school pretending it was like his like
secret agent shirt uh i was i was all in
at that point if you're sick of people
talking about resident evil 4
i understand why
but you probably should play it still
it's that good i just love leon so much
i guess i guess that's like
how i would end it just i love leon
and i want to marry him someday
and then you had the bella sisters we
actually made a whole uh theory that
they're all a
uh family of professional lumberjacks
before all this happened and and they're
they were participating in in carving um
championships and and getting a bunch of
trophies and then leon came in and
started killing all the villagers and
all their family members so they were
just they were just doing their part for
this intruder